we know we'd like to consider the motion
of a rigid body that's undergoing
angular acceleration about some axis so
let's consider for simplicity a disk and
we have an axis that's passing through
some point as here to the center but
that's not crucial and we want to
consider the fact that this object will
call this our z axis K hat unit vector
in that direction so it's pointing up
and this object is undergoing an angular
acceleration where alpha Z is the Z
component of the angular acceleration
now what we'd like to consider is the
torque on the subject so the way we'll
do it is will divide the object into a
bunch of pieces and let's identify a
piece here as Delta M J that's that
piece and this piece is has some force
acting on it now this force can be a
vector but the important thing to
realize is that this force is only the
external force because we've already got
to make the assumption that all internal
torques cancel in pairs and we'll show
that in a video a little bit later so
we're only considering the external
forces that are acting on this element
and recall that we have the vector R s
2j is the vector from point s to where
this mass element is and now what we'd
like to do is calculate the torque in
general torque is given by the
expression will sum over all the
elements j goes from 1 to n and it's the
back cross product of our SJ cross FJ
external now what we're trying our goal
here is only to calculate the z
component of the torque so we can
simplify our understanding a little bit
by writing out this vector F external
J as a component in the plane and in
order to describe that
we'll choose some unit vectors R hat
theta hat going into the plane we'll
make another picture in a moment
so our vector can have a R component and
I'll keep the external in there it can
have a theta hat component and it can
also have a Z component but recall that
a cross product is always perpendicular
to either the elements so when I cross R
with anything in the K direction then
that component will give a component
that's not in the z direction and so I
can ignore that
so my first simplification is to say
that the z component will only come from
the cross product of our SJ with these
two pieces
so that's cross F J our R hat plus F J
theta theta hat now again we can make
another simplification and perhaps here
it's helpful to have another overhead
view and here's our mass element Delta M
J that's our vector from s from the
center to Delta M J we have unit vectors
R hat and theta hat and so we see that
this vector RS J has some length in the
R hat direction
now because so we're not--we're picking
s as the origin of our coordinate system
this can generalize so we don't worry
about if the object is not symmetric so
when you take the cross product of our
hat vers r hat that also is 0 and so we
see our simplification is
quite nice that the Z component of the
torque is only arising from the sum of J
goes from 1 to n of our s J well we've
already will write this all as vectors R
hat cross F J theta theta hat now again
even if our external force by the way
we're dropping external we could always
say external but I think for simplicity
we'll now drop the external and what
we're considering is just the component
of the force we can write that F J this
is a little complicated theta just the
theta hat component of that force this
is the only piece of the force that
matters in contributing to the Z
component of the torque and this cross
product is very direct because we've
chosen a right-handed system where R hat
cross theta hat is K hat so we see that
this becomes J equals 1 to n of our SJ f
J theta in the K hat direction now
that's just the calculation of the
torque but as always it's crucial to
understand where Newton's second law
appears in these calculations and
Newton's second law for this mass
element Delta M J so the second law is
telling us that the tangential force is
proportional to the mass element times
the tangential acceleration of that mass
element now for this type of rotation
about the z axis so when we're rotating
about that z axis we know that a J theta
so that acceleration of this tangential
element is
proportional to our J the distance from
what we've called that our SJ so how far
away from the center and here's the key
thing it's also proportional to the Z
component of the angular acceleration
and every mass element in the body has
the same alpha Z and so our sum for the
torque can now be written in the
following way
the Z component of the torque now I'm
going to do something here which is I'll
write J equals 1 to n parentheses or
I have one of the RS J's I have another
RS j a delta MJ so I have Delta MJ r SJ
squared but every single component has
the same alpha Z and we're in the K hat
direction now because we have a
continuous body we have to again
consider a limit so let's call the limit
as Delta MJ goes to 0 of this sum Delta
MJ r SJ squared well that's an integral
over the body of DM R squared and we
identified that before as the moment of
inertia about the z axis so the quantity
in parentheses is just a measure of the
mass distribution about the axis you see
the R squared the Delta M J and so in
conclusion we have that the Z component
of the torque is equal to is alpha Z K
hat which is now a vector because that's
the vector alpha and this is our crucial
result for a body that's rotating about
the z axis this result can generalize to
not just a disc but any body that's in
looking at the Z component for this
fixed axis rotation